[Musique]
il m'entraîne passage des patriarches
dans ce xiiie arrondissement théâtre
populaire où les actes d'autrefois se
répète
par le passage des postes on s'y est
toujours vers le marché de la rue
mouffetard l'une de nos dernières
vieilles rues marchandes
[Musique]
et
la vieille baraque du marchand de faits
divers propose à la même place depuis
100 ans
son étalage d'illusions de rhel et d'
aventure
ici il y a un siècle l'on chantait la
complainte de la bergère d'ivry
assassiné à 16 ans par un amoureux déçu
à deux pas sur les bords de la vienne
cette ombre que j'imaginais je crois
l'avoir soul enseignes de la coutellerie
la campagne une dernière fois au matin
après le crime
où
[Musique]
non
au grand jour la ville hostile ne lui
ouvre plus que la porte des prisons
[Musique]
les vieilles prises en de paris sont
disparus
les fenêtres qui surprenait les amères
secret des cours de saint lazare ne voit
plus qu'un terrain vague
un pan de mur demeurent des arcades
sévère de jadis
[Musique]
où
les il est dans le sud de paris une
autre prisonnière à perpétuité
c'est d'être une fille de la campagne
une petite rivière venue de versailles
la bière
[Musique]
elle vient maintenant vers paris dans un
canal fermé pour la visiter il faut
emprunter l'escalier de service
[Musique]
ses rives autrefois habité par la gaieté
n'existe plus
[Musique]
elle se glisse entre les tanneries et
dans l'âcre odeur dès qu elles rêvent
encore elle rêve de pays lointains sur
les peaux mortes des crocodiles
[Musique]
que
la bièvre continue ainsi sa route vers
paris sous le ciment entre les anciens
lavoirs et les appentis où viennent
dormir les miséreux
elle évoque son passé léger sur ces
photos de jeunesse pour l'entendre
pleurer il faut s'en aller sous terre
à la poterne des peupliers dans les
aigus
[Musique]
e
pour
là la bièvre vit ses derniers instants
dans le brouillard unique
ces eaux ne suivent plus le chemin
d'autrefois qui passait par les gobelins
[Musique]
seule la trace de ses courbes demeurent
entre les usines abandonnées
[Musique]
voici l'ancienne petite vallée et les
rues qui l'abordaient
du rendez vous de chasse de genre
julienne où va-t-on venait se reposer
sur le bord de la rivière
voici ce qu'il reste
[Musique]
ceux des guirlandes fans et l'eau de la
bièvre se meurt dans les égouts de paris
elle se jetait autrefois à la scène à
austerlitz à la concorde la scène
indifférente ignore dans le siphon qui
les emmène du côté d'asnières les
dernières heures de la rivière perdu
curieuse destinée de la petite rivière
de paris qui n'est toujours mais qui n'a
pas comme la vie
[Musique]